[Music]
welcome to GameSpot's III 2018 stage
I am Matt Padgett and today I am joined
by Luke Eisenhower of raw fury now Luke
I'm a big fan of tactics so I'm very
excited for what you have with you today
some thanks for having me yeah so what
I'm showing today is a game called bad
north it's being developed by Oscar
Steinberg in Sweden and Richard Meredith
in the UK a two-man powerhouse team that
are doing a micro strategy game so
essentially if you've ever played a
games that are similar to you like XCOM
this is borrow similar mechanics of like
positional strategy where your goal is
to defend individual islands from Viking
invaders let's take a look at it sounds
good
all right so this is bad north so what
what exactly do you do in this game so
yeah your main objective is to protect
the individual islands from Viking
invaders so as you can see we're loading
her into the first island this is
generally what a lot of the islands look
like where they've got this layout of
multiple tiers and you pull in these
squads that you control their
positioning and so most of your defenses
are done on a positional basis so you
can select and then you can right-click
over here and you can send them to that
part of the island send that guys to
this part of the island and in just a
moment you'll see some ships start
coming in from the fog of war they'll
land wherever their ship is aimed at so
in this case it's going over this way so
in this case we'll want to position
these troops over around here so and
make sure that when they arrive they can
safely protect these houses the Vikings
are always going to try to prioritize
destroying the houses and if they can
maneuver around your troops they will do
so but for the most part soldiers will
just engage in combat and then protect
what they need to protect that's awesome
so I like I like the tower defense kind
of style it has yeah there's some
elements of tower defense built in
absolutely and much similar to that and
other strategy games right now we're in
the very simple introductory levels so
you know we've just got these swordsman
versus these swordsmen here but it
starts to introduce other mechanics of
being able to upgrade your squads in
two different types you know whether you
want to make them archers for some
ranged attacks or give them shields to
be more of the frontline at the vanguard
or to turn them into pikemen who were
really good at holding choke points and
you know holding down a position for
sure but then you also get some
counterbalance from some of the enemy
troops who will show up that'll also
have archers and can easily defeat guys
that don't have shields or you know some
of the really larger brute Vikings which
can really do a number on your frontline
now I see you're moving these guys
around obviously there aren't many units
on the field at the moment for you
mm-hmm is there do you ever get to a
point where you are like the archers
will always stay here or are you always
engaged and moving things around so
you're pretty much always trying to mind
whatever the best position is for any of
your soldiers but they do you might have
noticed and I'll zoom in a little bit
the next time we go into an island that
they tend to fear for their own safety
so while they will hold the position
that you put them in they'll maneuver
around the enemy and they'll shift and
relocate and try to just make sure that
they've got the most advantageous
position for the game so that you know
and that can usually result in any
number of things from you know your
entire squad getting split down the
middle by a boat that comes up onto the
land or you know you being able to
successfully flank an enemy by having
them you know become surrounded by your
troops
so positioning is definitely the most
important element here awesome I mean it
also has just an awesome art style
oh yeah reminds me a lot of a layer cake
so I kind of want to see a baker do
something with this like specific like
influences that inspire so yeah in
particular to the art style you know
Oscar would probably have to talk about
that in particular so I'm not sure what
his influences were but you know this
was definitely the thing that caught our
attention about the game first and
foremost it was just like how absolutely
beautiful it looks and these cute little
sprites yeah it's still like kind of
this cute but deadly effect going on
with like the blood spatter but
you know that can be turned off as well
for anybody that wants the game for you
know more family-friendly approach but
yeah the art style was just one of those
things that we immediately noticed like
oh my god this this game just looks
incredible sure actually the blood
spatter
when these these enemies come in it's
kind of cute it's funny like these guys
get attacked they kind of get smacked
around and then they fall into a puddle
of blood yeah exactly and so you could
probably just see where I'd here what I
was doing was we were getting engaged
upon by multiple sides so at first I
wasn't sure if I was gonna have enough
time to you know be able to send them
all one direction and then all another
direction so I'm choosing to split them
up and that can be you know for better
or for worse sometimes if these guys get
overrun I doubt that will happen but
it's entirely possible you could start
to lose troops like you can see the
squads already started to lose a little
bit the commander here in the center the
one that's holding the banner he will
always be the last one to go oh they ran
around me I don't know I need to go try
to catch up before they destroy that
house but the commander will always be
the last one to survive if the commander
ever dies you lose that squad
permanently you can take it in to any
further Maps and you lose as well any
upgrades and any items that you attach
to them which is something we haven't
seen yet in this demo so far but you
know that we can build up into is we can
find other islands that have items that
you can unlock and then attached to a
particular squad give them a you know
unique abilities or make the squad
larger or so forth so right now what
we're looking at here is this is the map
the map each of the islands are
procedurally generated and the map also
procedurally generates itself upon every
new playthrough so there's no way to
tell exactly what your island layout is
going to look like every time you load
into a new game it's going to change and
so the way this path thing works is so
this is an island that we've are these
are islands that we've already visited
this dotted line here shows where the
Vikings are going to invade next so
right now this island of stack is going
to be overrun in one turn thankfully we
already went there so we're safe we can
move on to the next
eventually though as more paths will
open up you start to have to make
choices about whether you're only going
to visit one island and let some of the
other islands fall or if you want to
split your squads and you you know half
of the squads go to one island half the
squads go to another island on the same
turn and so that way you can accomplish
more gather more upgrade tokens and be
able to you know speed along your
progression in order to keep up with the
ramping difficulty and then I'll show
you a little bit of what the upgrade
tree looks like so we go in here
and you probably saw at the end of every
turn we allocate tokens based on the
number of houses that you have
successfully saved and so this is where
you can go into the tree and you can
start to assign specializations so we
can turn them into archers so at the end
of the each level you were like hey yeah
and you have to choose before you leave
the map who is gonna get what currency
like what you want to do and yes it
definitely forces you to think
strategically and be able to you know
make choices that are gonna benefit you
in the long run so yeah right that gives
you three classes to choose from
archers which are really good at ranged
combat but suffer from melee encounters
if the enemy gets in their face infantry
which are kind of the jack-of-all-trades
in the sense that you know they can do
everything except range combat and you
definitely want them to be absorbing a
lot of the blows of the damage in the
front just because they hold shields and
they can protect against projectiles but
all in all their damage is pretty
minimal and then there's the pikemen
which you know as I mentioned are really
great at holding points but they cannot
engage in moved combat and they have no
defenses against range combat so they
can fall pretty easily if their
positioning is pretty poor but they can
be really powerful if you're putting
them in the right spot I usually like to
go with the infantry as the first
upgrade just because it's good you know
eventually when the archers show up it's
good to have somebody there that can
protect against some of the range damage
of course and so then here the next
island we're gonna go to you yes
question let's take a look at that
before we before we close out here yeah
this one's got a question mark on it so
this one's gonna have an item that we
can unlock and then one of the other
ones that was further up to the top had
a banner on it and that one is where
we'll find a new local Lord that if we
successfully defend against the invaders
on his island he will join us as a pair
Squad that we can carry on into other
maps all right so let's let's let's
close this out let's let's to go with a
big bang let's get those infantry troops
into let's get get them killing these
guys and then that'll be our finale
that'll be our big bloody finale sounds
good so then let's make sure that these
guys get to meet them head-on okay so
they're coming over here so I'm gonna
get over on this side and then we'll
just try to sandwich them excellent
oh they had no chance well hey thanks
again Luke that was awesome I'm super
excited to play it when can we expect to
see it and what platform sure so we are
looking at a launch timing somewhere
around August right now early to mid
August and it'll be coming to switch in
PC first follow it up immediately with
Xbox one and PlayStation 4 and then we
are going to be hopefully thinking about
mobile in the very near future after
that excellent well it definitely seems
like something I'd love to play on the
go thanks again for joining us and for
everyone out there stay tuned to game
spot for more III 2018 coverage thanks
everybody
you